let's talk about january 6. you can talk
yeah
so so we can't talk about uh can we can
say why you can't talk about
written house right i'm yeah i mean it's
a pending case
and uh you're a witness i'm a witness
right so we can get to the point of this
by talking about something else january
6
where the new york times they called you
a writer
they did in print they printed it oh
wait there was a correction that was
like
a number of pages later but you open up
the new york times magazine and i can
just imagine frame it my friend's
parents at home just
i'm gonna oh it's a nice sunday hoping
richie oh oh my god i mean actually you
know what
i'll take a death threat over i got
called uh yashar ali posted a thread
of photos of what that guy and i'm not
going to name the photographer
you know who you are you know what you
saw
and you saw me looking for my phone and
that caption still went in there calling
me a rioter
who punched a door and they issued two
corrections
and this is still outstanding new york
times you should still be scared
because what happened there was i
because
um of the way that i looked and because
i'd just been pepper sprayed
and because i had like you know wet hair
and i was
i looked desperate and i was they
labeled me as something and that image
that image and i got called a meth head
like 200 times and
um i don't know you you have press
credentials
yeah you got snatch for me that day
you're officially reporting and your
phone falls i have congressional press
credentials right
congratulations i can go in there on any
given day
and your phone falls and it's behind the
door
well i thought it was behind the door so
i was tapping on the window to ask the
police it turned out the guy
and that's the that's the most
objectionable part of this whole
situation is that
there was another woman who was
photographed two minutes later and it's
actually time coded in the piece
as two minutes later from my photo and
she's got a maga hat on and she's crying
and it says a woman was pepper sprayed
they called me a writer cause i'm oh
knuckle dragon trump's our border i look
like that
and by the way didn't vote for trump um
but i looked
to be that way they didn't they didn't
do any research and by the way they
relied on my reporting
after what happened in kenosha well so
they should have known who you know
let's say they didn't that you don't
look like a trump supporter
you look like a young white man would
look like a neanderthal
they could frame it like you were some
you know that's the narrative
i look angry and there's a broken window
and even though i was tapping on it with
one finger saying
please officers can you look for my
phone at your feet and they were all
obliging by the way
and they were looking down and they were
i was like yeah right there
is it is it down there tapping oh i
punched the door
so this this photojournalist they're the
one who lied
i don't know i don't know what the
editorial process was
i don't know who it was that wrote the
caption because in some news outlets you
know sometimes the editors write the
captions they edit the captions
there's a way to find out there is a way
to find out and
i can go that route i just have to wait
for my dogecoin to go a little
[Laughter]
and it's bumping higher now so so
there's there's one of two scenarios
here this is really important to the
conversation
either the photojournalist on scene who
saw what happened
lied because he wanted that juicy photo
look what i got oh i got that guy the
window
even though they knew it's not what
happened he lied or maybe he didn't
maybe the editor said hey looks like a
writer i'll write that down and did not
fact
check yeah if but here's the thing is i
don't know when the photographer found
out what that caption was but my point
is is that he was there two minutes
later
when that woman was photographed and i
was gone from that space and here's what
happened right after i tapped on the
window
every cop was looking down there were
like 10 cops on the other side of that
door
and i looked so desperate that they
actually obliged and then this guy
tapped me on the shoulder and said yo
man i got kicked back here
i hugged him i said thank you so much to
to all the cops i went down the line and
then i said thank you to everybody i
said please everybody be safe
i'm out of here i'm done for the day and
i'm not kidding people were clapping
they were like oh this guy found his
phone like he looked so desperate and
sad and now he found it
and i i hugged the guy i said can i hug
you and he said yeah
and so it was a scene it was a true like
anybody who's there
saw it and so i don't know if he was
looking down at his freaking camera or
whatever he was doing but i want to find
out media organizations
are putting out fake news making it
impossible for us to know what is really
going on
and so i was having i had a really long
conversation lawsuits are for
yeah but who can afford a hundred grand
and then the new york times puts a bunch
of their high-powered multi-million
dollar lawyers on it and gets to get it
crushed and said oh
it was an opinion doge is bumping right
now no he's just bumping i guess
i was talking to a friend man and it's
not a hundred grand but it it can't get
there very quickly
it's crazy how many people there are
that
don't know what is going on in any
capacity because they only absorb news
passively
so they turn on they were the new york
times yeah like my friend's parents
and they and they said i look like a
terrorist and i can never you know
and that's like you know what my dad
taught me to to stand tall
and that's what i'm going to have to do
here because i'm not going to let those
guys stomp on me
because they think i look somewhere you
look at the story the segment we were
just talking about before this one the
the gardener you know jay garner he took
his own life
the mob was coming after him you see
what happens when the media falsely
frames thing it makes them money
to get the mob all angry and you know
what man they don't care they don't care
they burn the system down i i genuinely
believe
i had a long uh conversation with peter
pagosian james lindsey
mostly peter progotion uh they're the
guys from the they're the and helen
pluck rose they were the crew that did
the
square house but i was mostly talking to
peter begosh about how i think the media
is the problem
and he said he thought it was the
universities talking about critical race
theory wokeness the conflict and
everything and i was like it is
i'm not saying it's not i know critical
race theory came out of universities
but it only found its path to the
mainstream because of
social media algorithms and media
manipulation then you look at the
the curve of all all of a sudden you see
all these buzzwords appearing
lexus lexisnexis data showing like
around 2010
the in instances of the word racism
skyrocket
like a thousand percent ten thousand
percent this is what opens the opens the
door
for all of this woke stuff from these
universities but i'll i will also
concede as well
that you had a lot of young people in
universities now entering the workforce
at a similar time being indoctrinated by
these ideas but i genuinely believe
the door was open because manipulat
social media news companies
there was this this nexus event where
social media was destroying news
companies
venture capitalist-funded firms jumped
in with no with no
care in the world for fact checking or
any credibility and start pumping out
rage bait garbage on facebook
drives everybody insane now now what's
happened is you can see this
the new york times quickly realized in
the mid 2010s
we can't compete with buzzfeed buzzfeed
can just say some crazy garbage
and get a million clicks we got to play
that game too so the new york time gets
on new york times gets on board we see
this
when like that opinion editor guy he was
forced to resign because he published an
op-ed from tom cotton which was like
standard procedure
but they're like we're going to do the
insurrection act right
yeah and they're like we're going to do
whatever the audience wants to make
money and we're going to we're going to
pander
they hired that that one woman sarah
jong who was posting unrepented racist
things on twitter for years but you know
what don't you don't you think that
we're
now in a diversion society where you
know like
the twitterati and corporate media are
going in one direction and normal common
sense people are going in another and i
just will say like
the one thing i'll say about kenosha and
i think that this is actually like a
silver
lining of kind of the
obstacle course that i had to navigate
in terms of dealing with the media after
what happened just trying to say what i
saw
so what happened was i went on tucker
because he asked me on first he was the
only
you know right after the shooting he
said you know you want to see what
happened and
so i explained on that show
live to his whole audience what i what
he told me he was there for kyle
rittenhouse why he was there
what he said okay what he told me cnn
then took that in a report
and i won't name the reporter but he
said
mcginnis supported the conservative
claim that rittenhouse acted
in self-defense and so then i emailed
cnn legal and i said um
you made a misstatement about me i
relayed what the motivation of the
shooter was
which he told me 15 minutes before this
year you were reporting yes
exactly and so you can do one of two
things and this is america
and when you want to get something done
you just threaten to sue people that's
right and i said
you can have me on to correct the record
or prepare for court and guess what
that reporter uh i give him a lot of
credit he had me he had me back on
probably because the cnn guys went to
the legal department said you better fix
this or we're gonna
you know and that was six minutes long
that they did and you know what they did
a very good job of covering the event
after that fact so well good for them uh
i worked for fusion which was the abc
news univision joint venture
i was in san jose and i was at this
trump event there was a
massive crowd running around beating
people it was it was insane they were
many of them were bernie supporters
i know because some of them were
carrying you know bernie
swag and said they were and uh
incidentally that's incidental this guy
comes out
and he's you know cheering he's like
yeah trump and they're all screaming at
him spinning on him he keeps walking
he turns the corner someone runs up with
a heavy bag and smacks him in the head
with it
he starts bleeding and i'm phil i run up
i'm filming the whole thing i he he
starts crossing the street the police
has quartered my chase chase him up
chase chase him down you know i'm
running after him i'm like hey can i can
you tell me what happened i'm filming
so i get this very short clip where he's
like i'm just walking and someone hits
me
the video gets like a million views in
less than a day i we
the pr team i believe it was pr at uh
fusion
immediately got hit up by fox news can
your can we have your reporter come on
and tell us what happened the the
higher-ups message me like hey do you
want to go like we do pr
do you want to go on kavuto and i was
like what's that like fox news and i was
like
should i i'm like it's fox news like and
they're like yeah yeah i should totally
do it and i was like
okay so i go on fox news and talk about
what happened i'm like yeah he hit with
the bag
we don't know what it was and then
people at the company
after seeing that i went to fox news
called me a white supremacist
i'm like but they told me to do it see
the people who are running the company
didn't know
what they were really supporting when
they hired young psychotic
woke cult members they were just like
it's young activists
so when in their gen x or mines they
were like doing pr is normal we don't
care if he goes on fox news but they
didn't realize that that the
tribalism of the younger millennials and
the older gen z was
if you dare go on and talk to any of
these people you are
them or worse it's an interesting
phenomenon don't you think there's a
flip side too though where there's like
if you're on cnn you're a communist or
you're not msnbc absolutely not
no absolutely not politics only flows in
one direction
if a right-wing person goes and meets
with the left-wing person
they call the left-wing person
right-wing
there there's there's no like a
left-wing person can go to a maga event
and they're like he's actually
right-wing
a right-wing person can go to a
left-wing event like the event was
actually right-wing
we put on an event called ending
violence
it was a meeting of the minds or
whatever ending violence racism and
authoritarianism
and we had daryl davis the famed like
uh activist who got 200 plus klansmen to
quit the clan he was our headline
speaker
and they claimed because we had some
right-wing people it was a far-right
event of racists
so even if you have you know daryl davis
and prominent
we had we had leftists we had social
justice activists they showed up the
whole event was far right they
threatened to burn down the theater the
theater canceled on us we had to move it
to a casino in order in order to hold it
and we ended up losing half our capacity
and we sold we had sold out so we had
lost a ton and
what do you do you threaten to sue well
i think that's the point is
you have to attack the gatekeepers right
and the gatekeepers of you know the way
that people especially after
all the lockdowns the way that people
interpret reality is through the media
and so if if something is being
interpreted
something that's happening in reality is
being interpreted incorrectly you go to
the go to the people who
who put that forth so you call me this
you call me a rioter
how did that happen i got two
corrections out of the new york times it
wasn't enough because they they still
printed
right the fact that i was a writer and
put corrections behind it want to know
why
because it's more expensive to reprint
right
and my reputation was worth i don't know
what was it worth i'm
i darn well would like to find out
because that was the sole reason why
they didn't reprint the actual caption
in assume i don't know what i'm going to
do
but i'm going to get to the bottom of it
i think you should talk to veritas
no i don't think i should at all because
they're partisan actors in my mind all
right
and i want to approach this from the
direction of truth and not from some
kind of
ideological side and i'm not like oh
take down the new york slimes because
they're all commies or whatever i i i
think well
veritas wouldn't say that no but i
understand that they're viewers i'm
being hyperbolic but yeah
i i you know they're viewed as a certain
thing right um
by you know the greater media and i'd
rather come at it as just an individual
who's trying to stand tall for myself
and um you know what if whatever maybe
maybe i'm a young young enough to enter
financial ruin for my
you know for the sake of the truth i
gotta be honest i think i'll settle with
you
well i don't care i want what i want
them to know is that i'm willing to go
the distance
in order to get to the bottom of what
happened and so if they want to settle
to just
set that aside i don't know if i'm
interested in that
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you